so Elvis mythical him the king of rock  and roll Michael Jackson the King of Pop  the king of hip hop I'm gonna get life  insurance okay last lyric I'm gonna  throw you I used to take for granted why  they placed me on the planet but now you  know yeah why did they place you on the  planet well his entire nation of people  that you know I'm guy from five thirty  four five see you know there was a guy  who live next door to me on top under  you know I lived in the project so  imagine the reach and you know not just  the music you know the movements of what  we were able to accomplish as you know  raise the whole generation of you know  people to want to do better for  themselves so you did it you're a  marvelous entertainer then I get onto TV  a lot I thank you for coming back jay-z  thank you